[Musique]
je vivais à l'écart de la place publique
ser un contemplatif ténébreux bucolique
refusant d'acquiter la rançon de la
gloire sur mon brin de laurier je
dormais comme un loir les gens de bons
Conseil ont su me faire comprendre qu'à
l'homme de la rue j'avais des comptes à
rendre et que sous peine l'ochoir dans
un oubli complet je vais mettre au grand
jour tous mes petits secrets
trompettes de la renommé vous êtes bien
mal
embouché manquant à la pudeur la plus
élémentaire dois-je pour les besoins de
la cause publicitaire divulgire avec qui
et dans quelle position je plonge dans
le stupre et la
fornication si je publie des noms
combien de Pénélopes passeront-il Lico
pour de fief et combien de bons
amis me regarderont de travers combien
je recevrai de coup de revolver grand
père que de la renommé vous êtes bien
mal
embouché à toute exhibition ma nature
est rétive souffrant d'une modestie
quasiment maladive je ne fais voir mes
organes pour créateur à personne excepté
mes femmes et mes docteurs dois-je pour
l'effrayer la chronique des scandales
battre le tambour avec mes parties
génital dois-je les arborer plus
ostensiblement comme un enfant de cœur
porte un saint Sacrement
trompette de la renommée vous êtes bien
mal
embouché une femme du monde et qui
souvent me laisse fire mes quatre
voluptés dans ces quartiers de noblesses
m' sournoisement passé sur son Liv vant
le soir et les parasites du plus bas
étages qui soit sous prétexte de bruit
sous couleur de réclame ai-je le droit
de ternir l'honneur de cette dame en
chantant sur les toits et sur l'air des
lampions madame la marquise m'a foutu
les morpions
trompè de la renommé vous êtes bien mal
embouché le ciel en soit loué je vis en
bonne entente avec le père du Val la
calote chantante l'ile catcumaine et moi
lesnergumain il me laisse dire merde je
lui laisse dire amen un accord avec lui
dois-je écrire dans la presse qu'un soir
je l'ai surpris au genou de ma maîtresse
chantant la mélopée d'une voix qui
susure tandis qu'elle lui cherchait
despou dans la tonure
trompette de la renommée vous êtes bien
mal
embouché avec qui ventre bleu faut-il
donc que je couche pour faire parler un
la déesse semb bouche faut-il qu'une
femme célèbre une étoile une star vienne
prendre entre mes bras la place de ma
guitare pour exciter le peuple et les
folliculaires qu'est-ce qui veut me
prêter sa groupe populaire qu'est-ce
qu'il veut me laisser faire
innaturalibus un petit peu l'alpinisme
sur son monde de Vénus
trempète de la ren mais vous êtes bien
mal
embouché sonnera est-elle plus fort ces
divines tromète si comme tout un chacun
j'étais un peu tapête si je me déanchais
comme une demoiselle et prenit tout à
coup des allures de gazelle mais je ne
sache pas que ça profite asse drôle de
jouer le jeu de l'amour en inversant les
rôles ça confè leur gloire une once de
plusvalue le crime pédérastique
aujourd'hui ne P plus
trompè de la renommée vous êtes bien mal
embouché après ce tour d'horizon des mil
et une recettes qui vous valent à coup
sû les honneurs des gazettes j'aime
mieux m'en tenir à ma première façon et
me gratter le ventre en chantant des
chansons si le public en veut je les
sors d'ardar s'il n'en veut pas je les
remets dans ma guitare refusant
d'acquiter la rançant de la gloire sur
mon brin de l'orvier je m'endors comme
un Loire
trempête de la renommée vous êtes bien
mal
[Musique]
embouché